we're joined now by the lib dem leader
sir ed davies thank you very much indeed
for joining us
you talk about ousting boris johnson
from number 10 going to crush the tory
blue wall it is a long ladder to climb
given the few mps that you currently
have how do you plan on doing that
we showed in the cheshire american
by-election at the beginning of the
summer
the liberal democrats could beat
conservatives even in true blue
buckinghamshire and i've been arguing
that there are a lot of seats uh in the
blue wall across the south end and
indeed in other parts of the north
places like cheadle and hazel grove and
greater manchester where actually
liberal democrats are the ones who can
beat the conservatives in some of their
heartlands
and when we listened to people in
cheshire they told us that they felt
conservatives were taking them for
granted some of them felt they thought
that boris johnson wasn't a decent prime
minister
and i think if the liberal democrats can
appeal to those voters and talk about
the issues i was talking my speech today
about education giving parents new
covert catch-up vouchers about carers
making sure we really have a supporting
package for people those looking after
their loved ones and small businesses
getting self-employed giving people a
chance to grow their businesses i think
if liberal democrats can appeal to to
parents characters and business i think
we really have an opportunity to break
through that brick wall
you cite the victory in the
and amisham by-election you threw
everything at that by-election while
labour didn't give it a huge amount of
energy how do you translate that win
when it comes to a general election
well if you went back a month or so
before the cheshire american by-election
there were the local election results
and across these blue wall seats that
i'm talking about in places like
wiltshire and surrey hertfordshire
oxfordshire cambridgeshire liberal
democrats made big gains against the
conservatives so that sort of backs of
what i'm saying and in quite a lot of
local election results since we've been
beating the conservatives in these areas
and we're getting the same message
wherever we go in these seats
conservative voters traditional
conservative voters lifelong
conservative voters pretty fed up with
boris johnson they don't think he shares
their values they don't think they're
listening to him they think they're
taking him for granted taking them for
granted and they're liking what we're
saying that we want to invest in their
children's education and so on so that's
why i think there's a lot of evidence
not just the cheshire and by-election
but lots of other elections in real
re-elections with people casting their
vote switching from from conservatives
to the liberal democrats that the
numbers though polling from yuga voting
in tension tracker remains low stays at
around five to ten percent the english
local elections from may you only gained
one council seat so i'm just wondering
what your strategy is are you going big
across the board are you going to target
those individual seats and if so what
are you looking at dominic robs and esha
and walton for example
well there were will be particular seats
where we campaign particularly hard uh
you mentioned issue and walton with
dominic raab he's certainly in our
sights but there are many others where
the conservatives now are worried about
the liberal democrat threat it's very
interesting we made one of our issues in
the cheshire mansion by-election when we
beat them so handsomely we made one of
the issues planning reforms because the
conservatives were proposing to give
developers lots of power and take it
away from local communities they were
proposing to not require developers to
build affordable homes for young people
and we opposed that we made an issue in
the cheshire american by-election and it
looks like those planning reforms might
be withdrawn by the conservatives
because they're so worried that we might
repeat our success in cheshire so i'm
pleased the conservatives are having to
listen to the liberal democrats and the
people of cheshire and american and i
think it shows that in these sorts of
areas we have the tories on the run
isn't power sharing realistically the
only way that you are going to be able
to enact change you say you're now
resolutely anti-tory you're positioning
yourself that way but would you consider
a coalition again
well as the conservatives have been
taking people for granted i'm not going
to uh our criticism of conservatives
have not listened to people
and responded to their concerns whether
it's on education whether it's on care
whether it's on business and i'm
determined that we don't uh therefore uh
prejudge the next election let us wait
let's try and see if we can uh do these
uh victories that i i think we can i
believe if we show a distance but look
at 2019 you only won in 11 seats that's
why i'm saying realistically it's not
going to happen is it
well um i think we're second to the
concertos now in 80 seats
if we won even just a small number of
those
boris johnson could lose his majority so
that's why i say liberal democrats but
it doesn't give you a majority a wider
movement
we're certainly not suggesting that uh
you know again we're not going to take
the voters for granted what i am saying
is that we can beat conservatives in key
seats that they need to hold and if we
do beat them uh that is
part of a wider movement that will get
boris johnson out of downing street
you called today for a focus on recovery
you've pledged to cut national insurance
for small business you've pledged a
green deal paid for with a green
investment fund
where does the money come from
would voters see more tax under the
liberal democrats and if so how does
that work with targeting the tory blue
wall
well as we've always done at elections
we produce
custard manifestos and indeed the last
election our manifesto was seen as not
just the most progressive on the
environment and on social care education
but also the most physically responsible
so we will be fiscally responsible but
you've got to look at the situation at
the moment
our economy isn't a mess
we've had one of the worst impacts on an
economy on hitting many businesses than
we can can never remember and if we're
going to get out of this if we're going
to
uh recover we have to invest investment
is critical so so taxes right or
tackling the climate change well a lot
of this investment i i actually think
comes from borrowing let me go back to
education uh we've taken the figures
from the government's own advisor kevin
collins who called for a 15 billion
catch-up fund for schools and young
people and children we agree with him
and what the we've seen elsewhere that
uh the impact of the loss of education
the loss of learning for people which
parents are rightly so worried about
it's hugely costly for the economy so if
we invest in children's future if we
invest in our schools and help parents
support their children better with these
kobe catch-up vouchers i've been talking
about that is the way to get a real
return for the taxpayer for the country
that's the way to invest in the future
investing in our children